AC crpol àple c'était une exposition
punitive ou c'était une Rix selon vous à
crépool la justice la justice le dira
mais il y a quand même beaucoup de
témoignages qui
confirment une forme d'expédition
punitive mais je suis pas juge je suis
pas au cœur de l'instruction mais il y a
des témoignages c'est c'est le procureur
de la République lui-même qui le dit et
c'est le président de la République qui
a parlé d'assassinat un assassinat les
mots ont un sens en matière en matière
pénale ça veut dire qu'il y a eu
préméditation donc que cétait c'était
organisé après on verra il y aura la
cour d'assise peut-être dans des années
se prononcera mais en tout cas ce qui
passé avec Thomas il y a il y a
certaines personnes qui disent c'est que
c'est du racisme antiblanc qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça en tout cas certains
propos euh tend à le confirmer les
témoignages qu'on a entendu sur planter
les blancs ou tuer les blancs le le
confirme donc il faut pas banaliser il y
a une immense émotion dans le pays moi
je voudrais noter le décalage entre une
certaine vision médiatique parisienne et
ce que me disent dans mes villages je
suis élu dans mon canton de de petits
villages que me disent mes électeurs
dans ma circonscription de Nice ils en
ont marre ils en ont marre parce que
derrière tout ça il y a la violence
derrière tout ça il y a une immigration
de masse derrière tout ça il y a une
intégration qui a échoué et tout ça
c'est parce qu'il y a ceux qui ont été
arrêtés à crépul qui sont sous souçonné
d'être les auteurs ils ont pour beaucoup
en tout cas pour la moitié des neuf qui
ont été arrêtés dont se sont en prison
ce soir il y a des casiers judiciaires
déjà lourds y compris pour des mineurs
donc problème de la réponse pénale
problème de l'immigration on a il y a un
journal Le Journal du Dimanche qui a
cité les prénoms des
personnes c'est un tabou c'est un c'est
un tabou c'est un tabou absolu oui ils
sont français
mais ça veut dire aussi que quelque part
ils sont on le sait et
les mots ils sont issus de l'immigration
ils ont été animé par une violence
absolue parce que quelque part le leur
intégration dans la République a échoué
et ça ça doit poser une
questionti sont des racistes qui ont
défilé dans les rues avec des barres de
fer ou pas pour vous bah bien sûr bien
sûr on voit les les relands de on voit
les les relands de tout ça encore une
fois moi ça ça vous ch ça ou pas c'est
faux de dire que j'ai pas condamné voilà
moi ce que je dis ce soir je dis très
clairement qu'on peut pas mettre sur le
même plan ça ne se vaut pas on n'est pas
dans le relativisme ce qui s'est passé
euh à crépoul ce n'est pas la même chose
que ce qui s'est passé à Roman surizer
est-ce que vous condamnez ce qui s'est
passé je condamne c'est la justice qui a
condamné moi vous savez je suis pas juge
il faudrait il faudrait que les
journalistes Pr pr aussi beaucoup de
recul et notamment dans certains médias
c'est pas à eux de condamner il y a une
justice il y a une justice dans notre
pays elle est
passée contact moi ce que je dis dans
l'émotion dans le pays il faut bien
l'entendre l'émotion dans le pays dans
cette France profonde elle est pour
Thomas et l'émotion médiatique elle est
pour ce qui s'est passé à roman surzer à
force d'aller dans ce biais on installe
un écart entre les Français et ceux P
quoi vous rpondez quoi ceux qui disent
sioti refuse de condamner une ratonade
bah je je viens de vous le dire c'est
une caricature c'est une caricature
est-ce que hier soir on avait les
éléments est-ce qu'il y a eu un blessé
vous avez dit qu'il y en a eu un mais il
était manifestement de l'autre côté ça
n'excuse rien ça ténue rien mais il y a
pas eu hier soir à ma connaissance sous
réserve de il y a eu des policiers qui
ont été ragés qui ont été outr
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
condamnations mais voilà un GR de
la police qui a intervenu très très vite
on est toujours dans des oui et je viens
de les féliciter il y a une forme de
raccourci beaucoup trop rapide voilà et
je le redit tout ne se vaut pas dans ce
pays monsieur chti vous êtes
parfaitement responsable homme politique
avec la molesse de votre condamnation
initiale vous légitimez que des bandes
organisées organisent une ratonnade dans
un quartier populaire vous rendez compte
c'est ça qui m'a choqué je tenais à vous
le dire les yeux dans les yeux tout le
monde condamne crpol c'est horrible
horrible la mort de Thomas horrible mais
ça dans notre pays c'est terrible
j'aurais aimé que vous condamniez plus
vite je n'avais un il n'y avait pas les
éléments et moi ce que je rejette c'est
que désormais on ne parle plus que de ça
et l'extrême gauche a réussi parce que
c'est sa dialectique bien sûr ça gêne ce
qui s'est passé à crépul Monsieur mé on
voilà ça gêne une certaine forme
aujourd'hui de vision communautariste de
notre nation ça gêne son excuse de la
violence et donc on est tous tous les
projecteurs sont désormais là-dessus et
bien je voudrait simplement qu'il
revienne sur ce qui est grave hein parce
que il y a le fameux adage quand le sage
montre la lune l'imbécile regarde le
doigt mais les Français sont pas des
idiots ils sont pas des imbéciles et eux
ils regardent ce qui passe ils regardent
aujourd'hui où sont les vraies menaces
qui menace la République qui menace nos
institutions qui nous attaque voilà la
réalité elle est là donc naturellement
il faut condamner et je l'ai dit hier
soir je l'ai dit sur BFM pour les citer
j'ai dit je condamne tous ceux qui va à
l'encontre des lois de la République
c'est justice de le dire ceux qui se
cachent derrière les violences à Roman
Surer donc ce sont des plusieurs
militants d'ultra droite euh qui semble
avoir été identifiés parmi eux un
certain Léo rivière Prost qu'on surnomme
grosardon euh selon plusieurs sources
cet hommeagé d'une vingtaine d'années
est un ancien militaire qui travaille
chez Lidl hein c'est ça absolument euh
donc ils ont des profils différents
c'est des jeunes adultes ils se sont
recruté et lui inquiète particulièrement
parce que c'est la résurgence de cette
fameuse division au groupe Martel de
sinistre mémoire qui commettait des
attentats dans les années 7080 et là il
y a une résurgen la brigade Martel ou au
nom de Martel qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
exactement c'est ça monsieur sooti qui
inquiète c'est ces activistes d'extrême
droite qui potentiellement sont
dangereux pour la République le danger
peut venir de là également le Dang
connaissez ce Group vous connaissez gros
lardon pas non je connaissis je
connaissais pas et j'ai pas l'intention
de le connaître et c'est bien qu'il ait
été condamné s'il a été condamné jeas
beaucoup je je sais pas s'il est
là-dedans naturellement c'est
condamnable c'est insupportable mais moi
ce que je dis c'est
que ceux qui menacent aujourd'hui la
République hein ceux qui ont assassiné
des Juifs parce qu'ils étaient juifs je
pense à Mol à Sarah Alimi à Ilan Alimi
ceux qui ont commis des attentats depuis
2012 dans notre pays voilà c'est là où
est la vraie menace et encore une fois
tout ne se vaut pas cette extrême droite
dangereuse néonazie elle doit être
condamnée avec beaucoup de force ces
groupuscules et c'est le cas d'ailleurs
ils doivent être dissous et ils sont le
et ils le sont mais je dis attention que
ça soit pas un alibi pour légitimer cet
extrême gauche qui est tout autant
dangereuse et qui a montré des signes
extraordinairement préoccupants
d'antisémitisme les mêmes que ceux de
cette extrême droite que vous dénoncez
légitimement Géraldine
monsieur Coti laisser l'ambigué à
Monsieur Mélenchon laissz le deux poids
de mesure à Monsieur Mélenchon pour moi
un homme d'État ce que ce que vous êtes
ça doit justement rassembler là en
faisant ça il y a pas de Battle en fait
entre Crepel et et roman suriser même si
heureusement il y a pas eu de victime à
roman suriser mais en fait on peut pas à
mon avis en tant que homme d'État et
responsable politique aujourd'hui dire
non mais là il y a pas une mort donc bon
c'est bon c'est moins grave c'est des
néonazis c'est des nazion donc de la
même manière que si ils sont allés pour
tuer des blancs ils peuvent aussi aller
tuer des Arabes donc en fait je pense
que on ne peut pas hiérarchiser je pense
qu'il faut faire corps aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'être d'être côte enfin Monsieur
monsieur Coulon est Mor au weekend voilà
il disait qu'on était aujourd'hui tous
confrontés on était face à faceace
soyons côte à côte et en faisant ça
alors j'ai pas dit que vous étiez ambigu
mais vous l'avez condamné un peu
mollement me semble-t-il on a
l'impression que c'est chacun ses
victimes chacun s'est mort chacun ses
combats chacun ses revendications
identitaires et en fait pour moi bah là
c'est gang of New York quoi on fait plus
République on fait plus plus corps en
fait c'est plus la France en fait mais
ce qui ne fait plus République bien sûr
vous avez raison ce sont ces actes mais
d'abord pour les français ce qui ne fait
plus République c'est le fait que toutes
les minutes et demi il y a un Français
qui est victime d'un coup et d'une
blessure volontaire 300000 l'année
dernière et ça on n parle pas est-ce que
tous les soir vous avez une émission
pour parler de de ces Français qui sont
tombéstisém de ces policiers qui sont
blessés moi ce qui ce qui mpile c'est
aujourd'hui ce oui je le redis c'est ce
traitement médiatique
différencié dès qu'il
s'agit et instrumentalisé par l'extrême
gauche et par Monsieur mélch Rais plus
pour faire pareil on va pas se battre
avec les avec les mê les mêm mêmes
comprenez que j'émett un sentiment une
réaction parce que on n'est pas sceptisé
et moi j'eni assez du politiquement
correct de la langue de bois des
éléments de langage d'une forme de de
prudence moi je le dis aujourd'hui je
condamne tous ceux qui ne respecte pas
les lois de la République mais
aujourd'hui le danger pour la République
c'est une extrême gauche complice des
islamistes antisémistes ce sont eux qui
menacent la République et ce sont eux
contre lesquels on devrait être
préoccupé et agir de façon déterminé
pour vous on est plus en sécurité en
France bah en tout cas beaucoup oup de
français ne le sont pas il y a des
quartiers qui sont devenus des zones
d'endroit est-ce qu'on a parlé on parle
tous les médias parlent de roman sur
iser dans le même temps le même soirée à
Dijon re à Dijon à Dijon un homme est
mort chez lui il do dans son lit parce
que des dealers ont rafalé la façade de
son immeuble il y a depuis il y a depuis
le début de l'année 49 morts à
Marseille dans ma ville à Nice il y a
des
dealers dans l'artère centrale avenue
jean-msin il y a la semaine dernière des
dealers qui se sont promenés avec une
kalashnikov dans le quartier des Moulins
mais est-ce que ça fait une demi-mine
dans un journal télévisé c'est ça que
nos concitoyens ne comprennent plus et
ils vivent ils ressentent cette
insécurité alors ça ne veut pas dire que
ça excuse les fait que vous dénoncé
légitimement encore une fois mais
permettez un moment qu'on ait un coup de
colère et que je l'ai et c'est ce que
j'ai eu devant ce journaliste qui
n'avait qu'une obsession qu'une
obsession c'est de ne plus parler de ce
qui s'était passé à Crépol pour faire
une espèce de dérivation médiatique sur
ce qu'il y a eu à Roman surizer donc ça
on peut faire tous les commentaires mais
aller sur le terrain parler au français
et de ça ils n'en peuvent plus parce que
oui l'insécurité et la vive depuis
depuis 2012 l'élection de Monsieur
Hollande il y a eu 111 % d'augmentation
des homicides et tentatives d'homicide
et il y a eu presque 70 % d'augmentation
des coûts et blessures volontaires je le
redis toutes les 1 minute et demi ça
veut dire que dans ce moment où vous me
faites l'amitié de m'inviter ce soir il
y aura eu dans notre pays au moins 10 à
12 personnes qui auront été agressées il
y a 100 policiers qui chaque jour sont
blessés c'est ça dont j'aimerais que
l'on parle parce que c'est ça qui va
protéger la République c'est cette
réaction dont on a besoin pourquoi il y
a eu crépole c'est parce que la réponse
pénale n'est plus adaptée parce que les
mineurs quels que soi les faits qu'ils
commettent avant d'aller en prison et
bien il y a une forme d'impunité
d'excuse de minité parce que aujourd'hui
avant d'aller en prison il faut avoir
plusieurs dizaines de condamnations
parce qu'on manque de place de prison
donc que ceux qui font des commentaires
que ceux qui sont dans la communication
permanente et bien agissent réponse
pénale adapté exécution des
peines exécution des peines exécution
des peine un
système un système qui depuis
2012 président de la République quand il
a été élu parz du garde des saau là
quand il a été moi je parle du président
de la République parce que c'est lui qui
fait tout c'est lui qui décide de tout
depuis bah bien sûr bien sûre des sa
tout est centralisé vers lui quand
monsieur Macron a été élu il avait
promis 15000 places de prison en plus
parce que pour qu'il y ait des peines
exécutées moi je dis pas que les juges
sont laxistes il y a des peines très
lourdes mais la plupart de ces peines
elles ne sont pas pas exécut elles sont
ce qu'on appelle aménagé déconstruit ce
qui est un drame pour les victimes parce
que les victimes on sentiment qu'on leur
a rendu justice dans une salle
d'audience et quand ils en sortent leur
leur ceux qui ont porté une agression
contre eux ils vont dans une pièce à
côté de la salle d'audience et on
aménage les peines dans la discrétion
pourquoi parce qu'on manque cruellement
de place de prison il nous en faudrait à
minima 80000 on en a 62000 il y a 74000
personnes déjà en prison notre société
elle est de plus en plus violente donc
soit on banalise soit on excuse soit on
réagit moi je dis qu'au-delà des
commentaires le temps de la réaction est
enfin venu merci Eric STI d'avoir été
avec nous tout de suite c'est magéon sur
C 8 on est lundi merci à
tous